I'm Bob Akbar this is my umpteenth
conference I've been to thank you for
staying so late this afternoon we have a
choice they gave me the last slot right
before the the cocktail hour so number
one I have to finish on time or since
there's no talk after me I can run way
over I will try to do neither well I
definitely get everybody out in time for
their the cocktail hour and I probably
have way more material than I could
possibly fit even in an hour but so you
can look at it at your leisure after you
download the notebook okay I'm going to
talk about reviving if you will old code
a couple years ago I had need to reuse
an algorithm for some interpolation that
I had done way back in college it was a
nice routine did very good and I said
you know this will be just perfect for
me the problem was I didn't have the
punch cards anymore and you know it had
been written in Fortran and I did manage
to find online the original publications
that did have the listing in the PDF
file and I managed to get that coated up
and Wolfram language and made it work it
was a bit painful trying to untangle all
that the go twos and everything the guy
wrote really good tight code but boy
trying to understand the logic from the
code next to impossible long story short
I did get done what I wanted to do for
the project and I'll show that during
the talk but in the meantime you know
after I got done with that did what I
had to for the project said you know we
had a lot of good work done with this
interpolation method back in college I
want it as a tool to use now but this
code I don't want to show it to anybody
even though it works so I went back to
the original literature found the math
that the guy used and said oh that's
what he did and basically reduced you
know three or four pages of Fortran down
to half a dozen
wolfram language code and that's what my
talk is to be about today number one
just because cold is written in
something like Fortran from 40 or 50
years ago doesn't mean it's worthless
number two a lot of times we have
algorithms that we use and reuse and
reuse and we keep them we keep you know
adding crutches and supports to keep
them working from one OS to the next and
so on but eventually you've got to bite
the bullet and rewrite it and this is a
kind of an example of that and the last
thing I want to point out is that doing
this work I had an aha moment that I
could extend this method to more than it
was originally designed for so I will
hopefully have enough time to introduce
that last part before we we finish
okay so what's interpolation I want to
make a quick distinction first
interpolation is introducing something
into something else okay
spurious or foreign as one definition or
calculating approximate values based on
bales that are already present and
that's the context that we're using it
okay that's from Miriam Webster from
Wikipedia it's a method of constructing
new data points within the range of the
existing data points or the known data
points and that's the context that we're
going to be using it and Wolfram
language there are a couple of ways of
doing this and I really don't like
presentation mode
okay so for the first example here we
have some data and we can do simple
linear interpolation which basically
connect the dots we could do cubic
interpolation which gives us a much
smoother profile over the data still
going through each point we could do a
spline interpolation which is similar
again going through each of the points
but you get a slightly different curve
or we could do what's called fitting and
here again we're getting close to the
points we don't actually go through any
of them but fitting requires a
particular model that is valid over the
whole set of your data interpolation
uses a model that's valid over a
piecewise segments of your data okay so
I'm going to talk about a Chema's method
Hiroshi akima worked in one of the
government labs back in the 70s and he
published a couple of algorithms and the
communications ACM and this is where we
found them at the time we weren't known
as hackers but you know when you stay up
all night at the computer center so you
can hack basically that's what we were
but we would code this stuff up because
it you know they were useful and it was
fun and you know we had nothing else to
do at night so the the smoothness of the
interpolation is controlled by the
degree that you want to use so here's
again just the the first-order linear
interpolation and it's just connecting
the dots I have a close up here of this
particular region right here and I'm
showing to Interpol once the Hermey
method is the default method for
interpolation you can say method goes to
supply and you get a spline fit the
problem about a spline fit is that they
you often get under shoots and
overshoots in your data and so for
certain types of applications that
that's not so appropriate we can
increase the order
of the interpolation and things get
smoother but all of a sudden we're
getting some really weird behaviors here
I mean overall this got smoother and
looked nicer but when we look up close
we see we've got a cusp okay and we can
go higher and it gets a little better
but we still have a cusp there and you
know it's not great so a chemists method
now I did open that section why aren't I
seeing it okay I'm gonna go to scrolling
mode
maybe this would be a little bit better
okay so a chemists method smoothes the
interpolation by providing slopes along
with the data when you call
interpolation you're just usually giving
it function values at some particular X
or X Y pair or X Y Z triple and that's
fine to do you know up to a certain
level of quality the by definition the
interpolation czar continuous their
piecewise continuous because they always
go through every point but they're not
smooth and to get them smooth you demand
that the derivatives at each point are
the same so now we are basically
constraining it and if you use a cubic
polynomial you've got four unknowns
a B C and D okay and if I use the two
points the values of the two points y1
and y2 as well as the slopes s1 and s2 I
can now sell for all four coefficients
exactly and so I'll have a piecewise
continuous and smooth interpolation over
the data and that's what it what akima
basically did and he provided a nice way
of finding the slopes numerically from
the data and when we use his method we
can see now his is the Green Line okay
for a third order polynomial the blue
line you see still has the cusp and the
green line goes through it nice and
smoothly because the slope is the same
for both segments this segment and that
segment so they join and they're smooth
okay so I found the subroutines in
communication ACM you know this is what
we did way back in the day we did punch
them up and and we use them for a lot of
chemistry and physics labs they were
great for getting a smooth line through
your data and that's that's what we did
so what I wanted to start with then
since I was quote-unquote in a hurry
I started with the Fortran I don't know
if how many of you guys have actually
seen Fortran but you know it looks like
this you know a lot of line numbers a
lot of go to here go to there and it can
be you know very convoluted logic often
called spaghetti code and I did get it
to work but you know it wasn't great to
look at one of the drawbacks of the
original algorithm that akima published
was that you would also had to supply a
set of points at what you wanted to do
the interpolation so you had kind of had
to know ahead of time where you wanted
the extra points to be made and to get a
smooth plot oftentimes we didn't have
enough when we have to go back and do it
again increase the number of points what
we wanted to use in between each of the
given data points so that was one
drawback okay so going back and looking
at the math if you start out if we want
to do find the right gradient or slope
at the middle point here point three we
look at two points to the left and two
points to the right and akima showed
that with this relationship here between
the points of our data and then some
extra points that are computed from
these data we can actually get the slope
at point three and that was the key and
all that Fortran can basically be
reduced down to these few lines of
Wolfram language code we find the the
interval slope so we find the slope here
which is really easy okay it's just a
divided difference divided by the Delta
X and then we can come from there we can
compute the slope through the
derivatives at each of the data points
and then we just give them to
interpolation okay and we provide the
original data and the data for the
slopes and that's enough to fit the
cubic polynomial exactly and that it's
smooth
and okay so doing that the results that
we get back from interpolation were
exactly the same as what I got from the
Fortran okay and what was published in
the example data in the paper which was
great so besides the the computation
that I had to do to get the data that I
needed to do the interpolation the
slopes being much more compact and
easier to understand I was able to use
interpolation to do the heavy lifting on
all of the the computation for me and
not only did that make that step easier
the result that I got was a function it
wasn't a set of points to be plotted or
whatever and I could use it like any
other numeric function I could
differentiate it I could plot it at any
resolution you know it was just so much
so much better than than the original
implementation and you know it was a
built in thing in the language so I
didn't have to do anything special that
way so there was an added advantage to
the user so the announced the for the
Wolfram function repository publicly
recently but about its beginning around
the beginning of the year internally and
they were looking for people to you know
make submissions to it before they
announced it publicly so I put this code
in there and it's really nice a nice way
to publish your code and they make it
really easy for your code to look
professional and polished so we can get
the resource object okay and we can find
out properties about it there are about
two dozen properties one of them is
called description that's something that
the author provides you can get the
documentation page for it which when it
comes up
okay looks just like the the built-in
documentation and that's by design
because as Steven demonstrated last
night the when you do the submission it
runs through a bunch of style checks and
make suggestions for you and points out
things that should be changed
you've got the details an options
section that you can fill in a lot you
can provide all the examples you want a
section for your options and you know it
all just works very nicely just like the
real built-in code you can provide extra
information about the resources you can
provide unit tests for example if you
think you know your code might be
extended you can provide tests for it so
that somebody extends it they can make
sure they don't break something that in
the original version so it's just very
nice to work with and and going back to
my talk okay
so to show an example here I have some
data and I'm going to interpolate it
with the Chema's method with the default
interpolation method and with a spline
method okay and let's see one thing that
we want to do is is get the resource
function object itself I can refer to
the function this way or I can refer to
it this way with the summary box I kind
of like the summary box it looks a
little bit nicer and so I've copied and
pasted that in you can use it just like
sine or cosine or exp or whatever okay
so we can do the interpolation x' and
then we can plot them okay and and we
see the same kind of plot we had before
and we can zoom in to the problem area
and we can see that in green a Chema's
interpolation is nice and smooth and
goes through everything very nicely okay
interpolation also allows you to specify
whether or not your data are periodic
and a Chema's method lets you do that as
well one thing to do that you need to do
in preparing the data to do the
interpolation is in the figure I showed
to interpolate a point number three you
needed two points before and two points
after well that's great in the middle of
your data but at the end points what do
you have out there beyond at each end so
he provides a very nice heuristic to
extrapolate some data points now those
data points that you extrapolate are not
actually used in the interpolation
they're only used to find the
derivatives that you then give to
interpolation okay
so to do a periodic interpolation all I
have to do is wrap the data around
basically take this five and seven and
wrap them out here on the end and take
the three and the two and wrap them over
here to the beginning to get a periodic
interpolation to get enough data to do
that and then just tell it that it's a
periodic interpolation and we can see
giving it just you know a handful you
know five or six points here we can just
use this over a much larger domain and
it's periodic okay what I wanted to use
originally was his spline version and so
I have that one coded up as well again
rewritten from the math and here's an
example of using it get the resource
function and then we'll use it here now
to do a spline it's actually a
parametric plot okay and and he wanted a
way to do the interpolation where you
could have multiple Y values at the same
x-value okay and you can actually have
your line loop all over the place and so
here's an interesting example of that
basically drawing some kind of knot type
of set of data
okay so the motivation for this talk I
wanted to do something outrageous for
the wool from summer school two years
ago and so I thought I could use this
spline on some nice data particular set
of data and get a nice image that we
could do something with so working it
out you know I loaded some data for a
graph and here is the graph okay and
what I did is I found all cycles of size
six and drew a spline around them okay
so instead of having to connect the dots
you know I would have over six points
here a nice smooth curve that would
undulate in and out and stuff like that
and in this case the undulation was what
I was after
okay so we find all the cycles and then
we make the curves and we get what I
call a braided spiky okay the original
points are here in here in here
and there and there and so on you can
see them where they intersect and then
lastly what we wanted to do was the
outrageous thing make t-shirts my
daughter who's who's moved on from
Wolfram was social media manager and she
was there covering the summer school for
that and we would sit down occasionally
at home and work on stuff together she'd
be doing her social media I doing my
consulting work and she would call us
team knock bar and so I had the idea
let's make t-shirts for that okay so I
got to this point and I discovered you
know I realized looking at the code that
we could do more and actually akima had
done more he had done a surface now this
codes not in the repository yet but I do
have it in a package and let me just
quickly show you what it what it can do
we can read in some 2d data and I can
just make a rough list plot of it here
and we can see what it looks like
okay it's just a surface you know some
ridges and valleys and things and we can
interpolate it there's the use its
message usage message for it here's the
interpolation over to D and when we look
at it we can see we have a you know a
nice much smoother plot here's the
contour plot of it then it works very
well the implementation when I rewrote
it is very compact again and if you look
closely at this code and the code from
the 1d you can see that he did X just
the way he did the 1d data then he did Y
by basically doing the same thing but in
the Y direction and then to get the the
cross derivative XY he basically used a
bilinear form on top of the two
one-dimensional derivatives and this is
all in his paper and I said you know we
can probably do this in n dimensions and
so you know that's my postulate I don't
have a proof for it yet but yeah I think
that that we can I've done a lot of work
toward that end and number one I don't
have a proof and hopefully Jonathan and
I will be able to get together this week
and see if we can come up with a proof
that for n n dimensional space if you
take the points of a hypercube in that
space and find all of the first
derivatives to by linear second
derivatives and so on up to D F of W X Y
Z etc in the denominator can you always
fit the cubic polynomial to that now I
demonstrated numerically that I can do
that to any order but I'd love to have a
proof a demonstration is not a proof so
I did a lot of computational exploration
about how could I do this and as I had
said you know in the implementation for
2d we took what we did for the X
direction and then we did the same thing
for y but to do
we use what was called a conjugation I
took what the the Y data I did a
transpose did my operation to get the
derivatives and then transpose back
that's the conjugation step and that way
I can use the same code for X on Y but
but getting things to work the right way
to do this in n dimensional space doing
all that transposition as a lot of extra
work and then the logic gets a little
convoluted it turns out it's much easier
to do if you do it with less convolve
and to do that you know think about edge
detection in images all they're doing is
finding derivatives in the x and y
direction where your image intensity
changes suddenly that's your edge and
we're just doing this in n dimensional
space and so the first thing we need to
do is find the edge detecting kernel for
the problem and here's just an example
of showing what the kernels would look
like for 1 2 3 and 4 dimensions and it's
really just a doing a difference is what
we're going to do and we just have to
nest them the right way to get them to
work at the different dimensions that we
want to use with liske involve and so I
can make some data here for dimensional
data and get the the X values for them
again this is just random okay we get
the size of the space from the length of
dimensions we calculate these kernels
that we will then use we get the
differences in each of the ordinate
directions the deltas as I call them so
we can use those in the denominators we
have to know which level that we're
going to do the convolution at with the
particular kernel and then we just map
the liske involve over each of the
dimensions and then we also use another
map on that result with the deltas to
get the actual
vitae differences or the interval slopes
and if you look at these here the
original dimension was four three five
and seven and each of these is reduced
by one I just want to make one more
point that to figure out how to do some
of the stuff a little bit later on okay
I made a toy problem here where I'm
looking at just symbolically what I'm
going to be doing and to make it a
little bit easier to see I just did it
on symbols of the axes rather than
trying to look at actual you know a 10
dimensional tensor and I can see that
I'm you doing one one first-degree
derivatives than second-degree
derivatives and then third degree in a
fourth degree in fact the third degree
in back to second degree and so on I'm
covering everything but the order is
messy and so with some additional coding
I'm able to extract the different
derivatives of a particular order out so
you get all the first order derivatives
in the order that I know they occur in
all the second and so now I have the
data to give to interpolation in the
right order so I won't go through the
rest of it I'm out of time I will hang
around for questions if you have them I
should you know I can get the 2d
interpolation out on the repository
pretty quickly as it is right now so
it's usable if you want to go that far
I'd love to get the nd dimensional case
worked out and then I'll just have one
interpolation function and you give it
the data it will find a degree and just
do it for you so thank you for your
attention
and I will see you at the reception
thank you
[Applause]
you
[Applause]